you know what sometimes you just need a
gaming headset that works one with good
quality sound a
decent microphone and isn't gonna break
the bank with all those extra bells and
whistles which is exactly what we're
going to be looking at today we have two
of the biggest names in video game
hardware razer and hyperx and we're
going to be taking a look at their
cheapest headphone offerings the razer
kraken x and the hyperx cloud stinger
both of which run for an msrp of fifty
dollars although it's worth pointing out
we were able to find both of these for
only forty dollars i'll say right now
that both of these are pretty solid
choices if you're looking for headphones
within this budget range but the
question is
which one is better let's start with the
razer kraken x it is pretty much a
paired down version of the flagship
kraken series in every way the frame is
made out of plastic which gives it a
very light feel
like extremely light like almost cheap
feeling and how light it is now granted
your feelings on this are going to be
almost entirely subjective the actual
build quality on it is solid and it does
feel noticeably less present when on
your head it's just a matter of whether
you prefer headsets with a heavier feel
or not if the lighter feel is what
you're looking for then points to the
kraken still i can't i can't get over
how light it is like i i know that's
part of the selling point is that it's
like it's really light but it's just
i don't know it needs more heft compared
to the more expensive kraken models
which offer cooling gel layer and heat
transfer fabric these are just your
standard pleather cushions although they
do have some memory foam inside and they
do feel nice they're pretty thick but
with an airy inside and i quite like the
feel of them i've used them for several
work days in a row and i found them
comfortable throughout as i mentioned
these are budget headphones so don't
expect any of the usual fancy features
you get with razer no rgb lighting or
anything like that what you do get is a
mute button and a volume slider on the
left headphone a cable extension that
splits it out into audio and microphone
and that's pretty much it you just you
plug it in and it
it works
so i am no audiophile but to my average
sounding ears these are pretty decent
quality headphones for the price range
i've tested them on the pc the xbox the
switch ps5 and they all sounded pretty
good i found the positional audio to be
pretty solid when playing multiplayer
games like destiny 2 and overall i i
didn't really have any issues with them
now as a bonus the kraken x does come
with an activation code for razer's 7.1
surround sound software it's designed to
simulate the positional audio provided
by 7.1 surround sound in order to
quote
give you a competitive advantage i don't
know about that but it is a neat little
thing and when i was flipping back and
forth i could tell a little bit of a
difference keep in mind that this
doesn't mean these are actual true 7.1
surround sound headphones it's simply
the software emulating that to the best
of its ability and these aren't gonna
sound as good as true expensive 7.1
surround sound headphones so don't go in
thinking that one pretty cool thing
though is that once you download it you
can technically use this software with
any pair of headphones so the last thing
to talk about is the microphone it's a
short
bendable microphone that stays out of
the way of your face in fact most of the
time i kind of stopped perceiving it was
even there because of how small it is
which is exactly what i like in a
headset microphone i i don't like the
ones where you just they're clunky and
in their way and you're just constantly
thinking about it so i i find that you
just sort of ignore this one with the
only thing that kind of sucks about it
is that it doesn't retract at all
meaning you just sort of have to bend it
up when you don't want to use it it
doesn't look that great to its credit
because of how small it is i again i
just sort of stopped even perceiving
that it was there and and after a while
it's fine but if you're looking for
something that kind of like looks nice
when you want to put it away uh this is
it's not gonna offer that as for the
sound quality you're not gonna be
getting anything amazing but it will
come through clearly on discord which
is what you want here's a sample of the
microphone from my producer richard
this is the razer kraken x one two three
four five okay let's move on to the
cloud
stinger
now compared to the kraken x this has a
much heavier weight thanks to the metal
bar in the bridge i quite like the feel
of it it also offers these 90 degree
rotations on the headphones this is a
feature that i've never really cared for
on headphones i just kind of find them
more annoying to hold if anything else
but when you're actually wearing them
the headphones themselves are very
stable very comfortable i do quite like
how it feels overall it is worth
pointing out that at least on mine the
right headphone does make a squeaky
sound when you rotate it
now compared to the kraken x the
cushions are a little bit thinner and
denser just a different style of design
for the cushion but i would say the
comfort level is pretty comparable to
each other the biggest difference to me
is that the ear hole is slightly larger
so they covered my ears better so if you
have large ears these might be the
preferable option now feature wise these
are pretty bare bones you get the same
extension cable that you get with the
kraken x and they have the volume slider
although it is a noticeably lower
quality volume slider it just kind of
feels like two pieces of plastic rubbing
against each other
yeah not great
the audio quality is on par with the
kraken x i tested it with all the same
games on all the same consoles and to my
untrained ears they pretty much sounded
exactly the same the cloud stinger
doesn't come with any sort of extra
software the way the kraken x does but
yes i did test it on the razer 7.1
surround sound software and it did make
a difference and once again we end with
the headphones it is a much thicker
design than the kraken x although it is
still relatively out of the way in the
kind of way that i like it also has a
little adjustable bend on the tip which
is good
and it has a nice little nook at the top
to tuck itself away when you're done
with it which is way better than the
awkward kraken x design where you're
just kind of bending it that said in our
testing with the cloud stinger the mic
quality is on par with the kraken x's
this is the hyperx cloud stinger testing
one two three four five now you may have
noticed when you fold it up and down it
actually makes a clicking sound and that
is the microphone muting and then
unmuting i mean you know when you're
flipping it up like this you aren't
going to be talking anymore so naturally
you want it to mute itself but at the
same time i kind of wish they had the
button the way the kraken x did
especially if you just need to mute
yourself for a second instead you kind
of have to like physically move it up
and down then everyone's going to kind
of hear that that muffling and scraping
as you're physically moving it
i can't imagine that sounds all that
great so
decision time
at the end of the day i found these
headphones to be pretty comparable to
each other and i had little nitpicks
with each one but
honestly they're really really close but
if i had to pick
i'd probably go with the razer kraken x
even though it's a lot lighter than i'm
used to with headphones and the
microphone it kind of just awkwardly
sits there i actually do like the
smaller size of the microphone overall i
prefer the mute button on the back and i
think i actually like the memory foam in
the cushions a little bit better really
though these are just personal
preferences maybe you prefer the weight
and the out of the way nature of the
headphones in the cloud stinger
hopefully i gave you all the information
you need to decide which of these two is
right for you if you're interested in
either of these headsets we have links
for them in the description below and
hey you stayed all the way to the end of
this video so why not hit the like and
sub button if you haven't already we've
got tons of great hardware videos here
at gamespot such as michael heim's
recent review of the xbox wireless
headset so why not go check that out
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you